families living in a north las vegas
housing complex say they are dealing
with issues of black mold and management
is not doing enough to fix it now one
woman says her family has been moved but
the mold is still an issue as victoria
saha reports that family says the mold
is now making them sick
we need help black mold making it nearly
impossible for sequaya armstrong and her
two daughters to live in their home
every time we walk inside we get stuffy
we get congested we can't breathe for
the safety of our news crew we filmed
from the outside this can cause someone
their life you know and god forbid that
has to happen for someone to tear these
complex down and rebuild them armstrong
has been living in the rose garden town
homes for almost four years she says she
has notified management many times about
the mold but nothing has been fixed just
because it's low income no income they
house people here and you know they
never fix the situation the problem is
management has changed throughout the
years fair stood management took over in
september of 2021 we went to the leasing
office where a manager told us off
camera they are aware of the issue and
some apartments have asbestos in them
but in an email from the corporate
management team it says they only knew
about it in april and took immediate
action armstrong says that's not true
they come in every
month or a couple weeks or so and
nothing's fixed i don't know what they
do armstrong showed us several work
orders for plumbing issues which could
be the cause of the mold it's at a point
where i'm scared you know we even have
rats in the walls the management team
says eight units have the mold issue and
have put those tenants in a hotel until
this gets fixed victoria saha live local
now